I'm here with Ben eater what do you do
here at Khan Academy oh I've done a lot
of things I've been here for a while so
when I first started Khan Academy I was
working a lot on that exercise content
made many of the math exercises that are
there on the site today and then from
that kind of shifted into a software
development role really trying to scale
also the exercise size for those of you
who've been using exercises for many
years now you you wrote some of the
software that created a lot of them yeah
well actually started with with you know
with you when you when you first started
with Khan Academy the exercises were
were things that you wrote as little
JavaScript things that generated
questions and that carried on until very
recently and so a lot of the work that I
did was building more of these question
generators that could generate you know
infinitely many problems so that folks
could get as much practice as they
needed and then so I build many of those
kind of following in your footsteps
there and then you know more recently we
were looking at how to expand that
because you know I'm one person it's
kind of hard to build a lot of those we
were trying to find more people who
could do that but it required this skill
set that was actually very difficult for
us to find of software developers who
were also good designers and good
teachers and you know we were looking to
to sort of scale that so more recently I
was working on building software to
allow non-technical folks to write
questions and so about a year ago I
worked on that had built out a little
bit of team around that and those tools
have now led to the fact we have a
hundred fifty thousand exercises yeah
it's it's grown pretty significantly
since then and the quality is is much
better than than what I was building you
know because we have actual you know
teachers building this not not folks
like me not robots robots not building
robots to write the questions right
right exactly yeah there's actually some
thought going into each one it's not
this machine generated thing that you
know has this algorithm behind it yeah
and so from that I
and now you know an engineering manager
working with a team of engineers to
build to know those things and many of
the things that are on the site and what
does an engineering manager do it's a
lot of things so there's the I guess
probably the most important part of my
job is is you know ensuring that the
engineers that are on the team are happy
and productive I mentioned that a big
part of your job is you know the
engineers you're incredibly creative
folks and kind of making sure that
they're how does that what does that
mean on a day-to-day basis what are the
kind of some of the things that you do
with with team members to to make sure
that happens
yeah day to day talking to them a lot
they're they're humans they have a lot
of thoughts and and just understanding
you know being empathetic to to their
their you know their personal goals and
their personal needs and their thoughts
about about the things that they're
building I mean there are 180 people at
Khan Academy now and we're growing you
know the the odds that me or you or any
other manager at Khan Academy has the
best idea our you know one out of eighty
because there are 80 people here like
most of the ideas are not going to be
ideas that I have or that you have
they're going to be ideas that come from
from elsewhere in the organization
making sure that you know I'm listening
to the folks on my team and for me you
know that that means you know spending
at least an hour every week with
everyone on my team one on one
there's having a conversation about you
know what they're what's on their mind
what their career goals are what just
sort of you know kind of picking their
brain and making sure they're doing okay
making sure they're happy and this is a
you know when you imagine when you're at
least four when I was young and I
imagine what a manager does
I imagine someone who's like telling
people what to do do this do that this
is very different than what you're
describing yeah yeah people don't like
to be told what to do uh-huh I know I do
and we hire really smart people it's so
like if I told them what to do they
would probably not do something as
valuable as what they would do if we
gave them a little bit more autonomy and
so you know a lot of a lot of it is is
helping making sure that people are well
aligned with with our mission and I
think most people to come here are it's
a great mission to be aligned with but I
think you know if if folks understand
you know
our strategy here and what we're driving
towards you giving them kind of freedom
the flexibility and the autonomy to kind
of build the things that they think are
going to be most valuable
yeah we've thought about even renaming
manager to support her because it really
is about empowering yeah I mean most my
job is is figuring out what's blocking
people from from being productive and
trying to remove those blocks yeah and
even this is you just mentioned like the
great ideas aren't going to come from
necessarily you know the hierarchy is
going to come from anywhere sure sure
I'd surface them and yeah and and we you
know collectively have thought a lot
about how to do that and you know we
have this process in place where anyone
the organization can can put together
proposals and you know a lot of
organizations probably have something
like that as a suggestion box or
something we take it very seriously and
we we want to encourage folks to to
submit their ideas and then work on
those projects and you know so part of
my job as a manager is really as a coach
to help people do that so there are
folks who want to you know they have an
idea they wanna you know surface that
and you kind of push no Khan Academy in
that direction
perhaps and they're really passionate
about it we want them working on that
thing that they're really passionate
about because that's where we're going
to see them you know really add tons of
value Khan Academy tons of value to our
learners and so my job is kind of a
manager is it kind of a coach is to is
to help them do that and maybe maybe
they don't have the experience of like
writing a proposal you know maybe if
they didn't come from a start-up where
they had to write proposals and pitch
investors you know that that's a little
bit intimidating for them to write a
proposal and you know catch you on this
idea I'm very intimidating yeah I try to
I work on this well maximize my
intimidation but you know you're not any
dude but I'm pretty togethers proposal
and trying to pitch it to - you know
we're senior people the organization can
be intimidating and it's kind of its
kind of a managers kind of a coach
helping people you know you know giving
them feedback on their on their ideas
helping them craft that document if they
want you know I can sit down work
side-by-side with them to write that
kind of proposal so really helping
people making sure that we are you know
getting as much out of out of each
individual's abilities as we can you
know you have a pretty interesting story
about how you discovered Khan Academy as
much of that as issue as you would like
to share that goes that goes back aways
I mean we go back to when I was when I
was in school I didn't I didn't have
I didn't have a great time at school
actually didn't do particularly well in
school at all you know always got you
know kind of seasoned B's and C's mostly
see grades in school and you know kind
of had this this sort of negative
experience I guess with with the
education system didn't really think
much of it and you know I did go to
college but didn't do particularly well
ended up you know failing some classes
and you know failing out of college and
it's kind of never quite understood why
because I felt like I was a smart person
but you know somehow the system had just
kind of not not worked for me and it
kind of you know system kind of failed
me but I was I was lucky in a sense
because this was in the mid 90s and I
had a lot of sort of technical
background my hobby was you know playing
with computers and things like that in
the mid 90s with the dot-com boom it was
pretty easy to go out and get a job even
without having that credential from a
school so I was able to kind of assess I
mean you were but in some ways you are
you're a tip coming you you were seeing
they're building computers in your
garage when you were in high school yeah
I mean I was I was lucky in the sense
that you know my grades were really not
that great
I kind of credit my parents they may not
have intended this but they they kind of
still gave me that space they saw that I
was like doing kind of I was doing you
know think like building computers my
garage and and they kind of let me do
that instead of like pushing me on my
grades more and I'm really glad that
that did that happen because I was able
to learn or teach myself a lot yeah this
is before the Internet so is a little
harder to do that but yeah but then you
know that experience did allow me to you
know to go into the into the workforce
which made a lot more sense to me coming
out of school and coming out of failing
out of school and build a career kind of
doing things with computers but in the
networking industry and software
industry
how did you first discover con-com and
you created actually a pretty robust
career in the networking industry yeah
yeah how did you stumble on Khan Academy
yes I was working the network industry
and then ended up you know starting my
own company in the in the networking
industry and build a network performance
measurement product and as I was talking
to to customers I was having some
difficulty explaining the
you have my product because my customers
didn't have as good a grasp on
statistics as I as I had hoped and so in
order to sort of understand the value of
my product I had to kind of explain some
basic statistic to them and I was having
some difficulty like explaining to my
customers what a Poisson process for
example was so I was googling you know
how do I explain what a Prasad process
was and I found I came across this video
that that you had made I remember that
video and it was it was very good and I
was like wow this guy is really very
clear explanations you know he seems to
really understand how how to teach well
which was something that was you know
important to me because as I said you
know school had always been this sort of
weird thing for me I never felt like I
did particularly well and it was always
curious why the system didn't work as
well as well as it could and so I found
this video I thought wow this is this
guy's really doing some some
groundbreaking stuff and I checked out
the website and I was like oh this is
really interesting and started going
through a lot of the stuff on the
website and I realized you know I taught
myself a lot of math in the intervening
years but I haven't really quite
understood why I didn't do well in
school you know I was getting you know
B's and C's in math and then eventually
when I got to calculus is kind of as
happens with many people kind of hit the
wall and started failing
I failed calculus I think I could took
it three or four times and failed in
each of those times and I never quite
understood why because I felt like I
understood the concepts but then when
they would give me a problem to do you
know I fell short and what I realized
actually many years later when I
discovered Khan Academy was there were
these as you called Swiss cheese gaps in
my knowledge or things that I should
have learned back in eighth grade that I
just didn't know and you know when I was
expected to apply them in calculus it
wasn't the calculus that was tripping me
up it was these things from eighth grade
it was tripping me up until I discovered
that on Khan Academy it kind of went
through literally all the content that
you had
then about almost 4 years ago and
thought well this is amazing and as I
was going through that I found a you
know a small little bug on the website
and reported the bug and it was take it
took me to at the time I think a lot of
the the website was open source and so I
was able to actually look at the source
code and fix the bug and so I submitted
a patch you guys accepted it and then I
got a little bit more involved and
started submitting larger patches like a
suggested code change
yeah code change so I found the bug
fixed the bug and then submitted that
fix to you guys and and then I started
started working on some other things and
started adding some
some content I'm submitting some some
content for you guys to add I guess I
guess you guys liked it I got I got some
emails and then eventually you called me
yeah this is kind of a surreal
experience for me I felt like I but well
we saw it when you submitted the
derivative intuition we have said this
person has deep understanding of
calculus hey you didn't suspect that I
failed it but it goes to show you
actually clearly do have deep
understanding of amongst many other
things you're not making videos on how
you know semiconductors and transistors
and whatever else works and anyone who
watches those would recognize your deep
understanding but it was one of these
things that you had you know I think
when you say those negative exponents
that was tripping you up
yeah negative exponent rules exponent
rules you just had that gap build you
would have probably ace calculus and
maybe become a math professors yeah I
mean I this is where's the like I
understood what a derivative was I knew
how to how to apply the power rule but
then as soon as you asked me what's the
derivative of 1 over X no idea what to
do like we had how does this apply to
our multiplying yeah no well I'm glad
you've taken this and and what you know
what kind of gets you up in the morning
what are you excited about Khan Academy
what you're doing I mean obviously just
super passionate about the mission you
know I you know for me it's it's a very
personal visceral thing you know because
as I you know the story we just talked
about you know I felt like school and
had failed me in some way and it was and
it's very much goes to this was cheese
gaps you know that whatever that day I
missed in eighth grade huh negative
exponents that just you know kept
following me and I had no idea how to
solve that I had
fantastic math teacher actually in high
school learned a ton from him but he
wasn't really equipped to diagnose that
that problem that you know he was only
right missed this concept and so I
learned a ton in this class but and you
know learn to love for math but but also
you know he was giving me c's couldn't
do the work
yeah and said and so knowing that that
we are creating this resource that if
had it existed back then would have
completely removed those obstacles from
me is very meaningful to me and I feel
like I got very lucky
based on just sort of my experience with
the tinkering that I had done and the
applicability you know and the ease of
you know being able to get a job and the
peak of the dot-com boom you know
without an education like that was very
lucky I think and I think most folks
might not might not have that luck and
so knowing that we're building something
that you know that there's going to help
a lot of folks who could very
understandably be in that situation and
not not get as lucky as I did is very
meaningful that gets me up ya know well
it's an honor to work with you
likewise